depuis lundi beau temps mauvais temps 22
millions de pékinois doivent faire la
file pour se faire tester à part ces
centres de dépistage les lieux publics
sont interdits les activités culturelles
annulés et les écoles seront toutes
fermées à compter de demain hélas les
vols ont été annulés les trains ont été
annulés et les gens ne peuvent pas
quitter pékin c'est là vers la même
situation dans de nombreuses autres
villes donc voilà la ville et la vie
tourne quand même au ralenti cet
isolement de la capitale chinoise
pourrait s'intensifier dès ce week-end
si le dépistage des derniers jours
confirment une augmentation des quatre
co vide actuellement la stratégie du
gouvernement chinois serait de confiner
la ville de pékin au complet ce qui va
avoir un énorme impact économique social
et comme je faisais sur la santé mentale
depuis deux ans la stratégie zéro que
vides avait permis à la chine de limiter
de façon spectaculaire le nombre de cas
et de décès liés aux coronavirus ce
n'est plus le cas avec les variants au
micro beaucoup plus contagieux que les
précédents les chinois sont aujourd'hui
plus vulnérables parce qu'ils sont
beaucoup moins vacciner pourquoi est ce
que il n'y a pas eu de priorité accordée
à la vaccination
simplement parce qu'on se rend compte
que les vaccins chinois sont assez peu
efficace et que la chine ne veut pas
pour des raisons le disons le
nationaliste apporter des vaccins
étrangers même avec ce vaccin là qui est
moins efficace
ça aurait quand même permis dans une
certaine mesure de réduire la
circulation du virus et surtout de
réduire le développement de symptômes
graves et donc d'hospitalisation
les scènes de chaos et de colère qu'on
voit à shanghai qui est strictement
confiné depuis un mois pourrait-elle se
répéter à pékin jusqu'à présent il y
avait un soutien massif de la population
à la politique du gouvernement la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement
les gens avaient peur du coc vide
maintenant ils commencent à avoir peur
de la politique du gouvernement face au
co vidéo ce sera un tel symbole si pékin
à la capitale pékin et le siège du
pouvoir du parti communiste était
totalement confinés à que le reste du
monde vit normalement ce serait le
symbole d'un tel échec que ça pourrait
avoir des conséquences politiques au
niveau international et au niveau
national avec une cinquantaine de villes
confiné des milliers d' usine fermée les
conséquences économiques sont déjà
catastrophique quand vous avez la
capitale économique du pays qui est
bloqué pendant un mois y compris avec le
port de shanghai qui a des plus grands
ports voir le plus grand port du monde
c'est évident que tout est bloqué il est
évident que si pékin étaient confinés
même si shanghai rouvrent peu à peu la
mécanique se bloquera la crainte d'une
récession pourrait peut-être convaincre
le parti communiste chinois à ne pas
confiné pékin ici se fit langlois radio
canada montréal